Our story begins in 1982. CNN is only a few years old. Newspaper circulation isn't an all-time high, and every morning, around a million children take to their paper routes to deliver the morning news. On September 5, 1982, one of those children was a boy named Johnny Gosh, who slipped out of his house in West Des Moines, Iowa, before the sun came up, while his mom and dad were still asleep in their bed. We were awakened by the phone ringing.
我们的故事始于 1982 年。CNN 当时才成立几年。报纸发行量并未达到历史最高水平，每天早晨，大约有上百万名儿童开始他们的送报路线，去分发晨间新闻。1982 年 9 月 5 日，这些孩子中有一个名叫约翰尼·戈什（Johnny Gosh）的男孩，他在太阳升起之前溜出了位于爱荷华州西得梅因的家，当时他的父母还在床上熟睡。我们被一阵电话铃声吵醒。
That's Noring Gosh, Johnny's mother. It was the neighbor saying they did not receive their newspapers. This wasn't like Johnny. He'd never missed a delivery. His dad got up and said, I'll go help him finish the route. He's probably just running late. So he went up the street, and that's where he saw Johnny's wagon sitting. Johnny's red wagon was sitting at the corner.
那是诺琳·戈什（Noring Gosh），约翰尼的母亲。是邻居打来的，说他们没有收到报纸。这可不像约翰尼会做的事。他从未漏掉过一次投递。他的爸爸起床说：“我去帮他送完剩下的。他大概只是迟到了。”于是他沿着街道走去，就在那里他看到了约翰尼的手推车。约翰尼的红色手推车正停在街角。
It was still full of newspapers. So he rushed back and told me Johnny was gone and to call the police. Johnny Gosh was 12 when he disappeared. He had blue eyes and dirty blonde hair with a small gap between his front teeth. And his face would be on the very first milk carton to ever feature a missing child. I have a distinct memory of being a kid and just staring at the milk carton with this blurry face on it. That's reporter Annie Brown. Which is weird because I definitely wasn't alive to see one.
车里还装满了报纸。于是他赶忙跑回来告诉我，约翰尼不见了，让我报警。约翰尼·戈什失踪时只有 12 岁。他有着蓝色的眼睛和一头深金色头发，门牙之间有一条小缝。他的脸将成为历史上第一个印有失踪儿童形象的牛奶盒封面。我对作为一个孩子时，盯着牛奶盒上那张模糊面孔的经历有着清晰的记忆。那是记者安妮·布朗（Annie Brown）。这很奇怪，因为我绝对没有经历过那个时代。
The Mill Carton campaign only lasted a few years in the 80s, but it left an indelible mark on our culture. It introduced a kind of mythology around child safety that lingers to this day. And it changed what exactly Americans are afraid of when we fear for our children. From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States and 100 Objects. I'm Roman Mars. Today, the missing children milk carton. The morning that Johnny disappeared, Noreen said it took 45 minutes for the police to arrive. So she called around to the other boys who delivered papers that morning.
牛奶盒运动在 20 世纪 80 年代只持续了几年，但它在我们的文化中留下了不可磨灭的印记。它围绕儿童安全引入了一种延续至今的神话。它改变了美国人在为孩子担心时，所恐惧的事物究竟是什么。本节目由 99% Invisible 与 BBC Studios 联合制作，为您带来《美国简史与 100 件物品》。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。今天的主题是：失踪儿童牛奶盒。约翰尼失踪的那个早晨，诺琳说警察花了 45 分钟才赶到。于是她给那天早上送报的其他男孩打了电话。
A few of them said they saw her son talking to a man in a blue car, but the police were skeptical. The cop looked at me and said, well, has your son ever run away before? And I said, well, no, he's never run away ever, nor did he run away today. This was Iowa. This kind of thing wasn't supposed to happen to kids like Johnny in places like Iowa. We'd never had a crime like this before. This was before Amber Alerts, before those text messages that you get when a kid goes missing. There wasn't even a category for missing children.
他们中有几个人说，看到她的儿子和一个开着蓝色汽车的男人说话，但警察对此持怀疑态度。警察看着我说：“好吧，你儿子以前离家出走过吗？”我说：“没有，他从来没有离家出走过，今天也没有。”这里是爱荷华州。这种事情本不应该发生在像约翰尼这样的人身上，在爱荷华州这样的小地方。我们以前从未发生过这样的罪案。这是安珀警报（Amber Alerts）出现之前，也是你在孩子失踪时收到的那些短信出现之前。当时甚至还没有“失踪儿童”这一分类。
kids were put in the same group as missing adults, and an adult had to be gone for three days before they were considered missing. So without the police's help, Johnny's parents tried everything they could to find him. They hired private investigators and coordinated search parties. Meanwhile, as they searched, they also wrote Iowa state legislation that would differentiate missing children from missing adults. I wrote the John of Gosh law at my kitchen table. But after all of this, Noreen's son was still gone. And then two years later, in 1984, another little boy disappeared while delivering newspapers. He lived in a neighborhood not far from Johnny's.
孩子们被归入与失踪成年人相同的组别，而成年人必须失踪三天才能被视为失踪人员。因此，在没有警方帮助的情况下，约翰尼的父母尝试了他们能做到的一切来寻找他。他们雇用了私家侦探并协调搜救队。与此同时，在搜寻的过程中，他们还起草了爱荷华州立法，旨在将失踪儿童与失踪成年人区分开来。我在厨房的桌子上写下了《约翰尼·戈什法》。但经历了这一切之后，诺琳的儿子依然不见踪影。两年后的 1984 年，又有一个小男孩在送报时失踪了。他住在离约翰尼家不远的一个社区里。
Eugene Martin was last seen delivering newspapers between 5.30 and 6 that morning. His paper bag with newspapers still inside was found just outside of Des Moines. This second paper boy had a relative who worked at a local dairy. The Anderson and Erickson Derry. That relative and the dairy's owner came up with an idea to help find these boys. The Anderson-Eriks & Derry contacted each family, and they wanted to do something helpful in the investigations. And within a few short weeks, thousands of milk cartons were rolled out of trucks and into grocery stores all over Des Moines. As clerks stocked their shelves, the faces of Johnny Gosh and Eugene Martin, smile.
尤金·马丁（Eugene Martin）最后一次被人看到是在那天早上 5 点半到 6 点之间送报。装着报纸的纸袋依然留在得梅因郊外。第二个送报男孩有一个在当地乳制品厂工作的亲戚。安德森-埃里克森乳业（The Anderson and Erickson Dairy）。这位亲戚和乳品厂老板想出了一个帮助寻找这些男孩的主意。安德森-埃里克森乳业联系了每个家庭，他们希望在调查中做一些有帮助的事情。在短短几周内，成千上万的牛奶盒从卡车上卸下，进入了得梅因各地的杂货店。当店员们将它们摆上货架时，约翰尼·戈什和尤金·马丁的微笑……
The campaign started at one local dairy, but over the next few weeks, it spread to other Midwestern towns. And in Illinois, dairy saw it and said, why don't we try that? And from there, it went national. Nearly everybody drinks milk. Milk also turns over quickly, so we could put a lot of different kids' photos on and pull children's off that needed to come off. That's Barbara Huggett.
这场运动始于一家当地的乳制品厂，但在接下来的几周里，它蔓延到了中西部的其他城镇。伊利诺伊州的一家乳制品厂看到后说：“我们为什么不也试试呢？”从那以后，它走向了全国。几乎每个人都喝牛奶。牛奶的流通速度也很快，所以我们可以把许多不同孩子的照片印上去，并把那些需要撤下的孩子的照片换下来。那是芭芭拉·哈吉特（Barbara Huggett）。
She was working as an artist at the National Child Safety Council in Michigan when the milk carton campaign took off. Our founder, apparently he'd seen Johnny Gosh and Eugene Martin on the Anderson-Erickson dairy milk cartons, but he felt that the program should be nationwide. A nationwide milk carton campaign would alert families in California to look for a child that went missing in Iowa. The national campaign brought together local groups looking for missing children, and together they came up with an initial list of 77 kids from all over the country. We used cases that were believed to be what they termed in those days dangerous stranger abductions. In other words, kids that weren't taken by someone they knew.
当牛奶盒运动兴起时，她正在密歇根州的全国儿童安全委员会（National Child Safety Council）担任美工。我们的创始人显然在安德森-埃里克森乳业的牛奶盒上看到了约翰尼·戈什和尤金·马丁，但他觉得这个项目应该在全国范围内推开。全国性的牛奶盒运动将提醒加利福尼亚州的家庭寻找在爱荷华州失踪的孩子。全国运动将寻找失踪儿童的当地组织聚集在一起，他们共同列出了来自全国各地的 77 名儿童的初始名单。我们采用了那些被认为是他们那个时代所谓的“危险陌生人绑架”的案件。换句话说，就是没有被他们认识的人带走的孩子。
Barb's team didn't have computers, so they cut and arranged all the layouts by hand. We designed a layout that was just, you know, rather simple. In black block letters, the word missing was printed across the top of each waxy paper panel. photos of two children were laid side by side in black and white. Under the photos where there are dates of birth, height, weight, and where they were last seen. They also printed the pictures on school milk cartons, but only one child could fit on those. The National Child Safety Council reached out to dairies all over the country, asking if they'd be part of the campaign. Within months, 700 independent dairies had signed on.
芭芭拉的团队没有电脑，所以他们手工裁剪和排版了所有设计。我们设计了一个相当简单的版式。在黑色粗体字母中，“失踪”（missing）这个词印在每个蜡纸版块的顶部。两个孩子的照片黑白相间地并排摆放。照片下方是他们的出生日期、身高、体重以及最后一次被看到的地方。他们还将照片印在学校的牛奶盒上，但这些盒子上只能容纳一个孩子。全国儿童安全委员会联系了全国各地的乳制品厂，询问他们是否愿意参与这项运动。几个月内，就有 700 家独立乳制品厂签约加入。
Boy, I wish I knew how many cartons had circulated. I imagine it's way into the billions when you have 700, 750 dairies printing day in and day out for years. Some sources have estimated that as many as 5 billion milk cartons were printed with the faces of missing children. Five billion milk cartons telling every American family this could happen to your kid. It's every parent's worst nightmare. As I said, we had not had cases of this going on in our community. Johnny's was the first really big case to hit. Johnny's may have been the first big case to hit
天哪，我真希望我知道发行了多少个牛奶盒。我想当你有 700、750 家乳品厂日复一日、年复一年地印刷时，数量已经达到了几十亿。一些消息来源估计，有多达 50亿个牛奶盒印上了失踪儿童的面孔。五十亿个牛奶盒在告诉每一个美国家庭，这可能会发生在你的孩子身上。这是每个父母最大的噩梦。正如我所说，我们的社区以前没有发生过这样的案件。约翰尼的是第一起真正轰动的大案。约翰尼的案子可能是第一起轰动的案件……
and the first to spark the National Milk Carton campaign, but there had been previous kidnappings of other children in other places that hadn't sparked the same outrage. It's interesting. In Atlanta, there were two young boys who also went missing at around the same time in July of 1979. This is historian Paul Renfro. And this didn't really initiate the same sort of panic, the same sort of concern that you saw in Iowa
也是第一起引发全国牛奶盒运动的案件，但在此之前，其他地方也发生过其他儿童绑架案，却没有引发同等的愤怒。这很有趣。在亚特兰大，也有两个小男孩在 1979 年 7 月左右的大致同一时间失踪。这是历史学家保罗·伦弗罗（Paul Renfro）。但这并没有真正引发在爱荷华州因两名送报男孩失踪而引发的那种恐慌和关注。在亚特兰大失踪的不仅仅是两个男孩。而是一整串人。看到世界做出的反应如此截然不同，真是令人震惊。首先，一个 14 岁的男孩名叫特迪·史密斯（Teddy Smith）失踪了。四天后，13 岁的阿尔弗雷德·埃文斯（Alfred Evans）失踪。几个月后，另一个 14 岁的男孩在为妈妈去银行的路上消失了，接着是一个为邻居跑腿的九岁男孩。全国主流媒体基本保持沉默。
with the disappearances of two paper boys. It wasn't just two boys in Atlanta who disappeared. It was a whole slew of them. And it's striking to see just how differently the world responded. First, a 14th. year old boy named Teddy Smith went missing. Four days later, 13-year-old Alfred Evans disappears. A few months after that, another 14-year-old vanishes on the way to the bank for his mom, then a nine-year-old running an errand for a neighbor. The national media was largely quiet.
没有创新性的运动来寻找他们，但这种事一次又一次地发生。事实上，在两年的时间里，有 29 名儿童和年轻人 在亚特兰大失踪。一个明显的区别是，这些孩子全部都是黑人。所有这些年轻人都是非裔美国人，围绕它的舆论，除了受害者的家属之外，并没有来自公众的真正的呐喊。为什么亚特兰大的绑架事件没有引发类似运动？我认为这与我们对童年和童年纯真的理解有关。
There was no innovative campaign to find them, but it happened over and over again. In fact, over the course of two years, 29 kids and young people disappeared in Atlanta. One clear difference was that all of these children were black. All of these youths were African American, and the discourse around it, there was no real kind of cry from the public apart from the victim's families. And why didn't the Atlanta kidnappings lead to like a similar campaign? I think it has to do with our understandings of childhood and childhood innocence.
我认为这些事情总是以非常特定的大众心理被种族化。因此，那些如此轻易地贴在爱荷华州的约翰尼·戈什和尤金·韦德·马丁以及其他失踪或遇害的白人儿童身上的纯真描述，并没有被应用到在亚特兰大被绑架和杀害的年轻人身上。他们经常被描述为精明、街头混混。因此，在某种程度上，围绕他们失踪和死亡的一些言论，反而起到了使他们的失踪和死亡合理化的作用。亚特兰大被绑架的许多儿童在失踪后的几周和几个月内被发现已经死亡。但有些人依然下落不明。然而，他们中没有一个人出现在全国儿童安全委员会的牛奶盒运动中。即使对于那些最终登上牛奶盒的孩子来说，这项运动也基本算不上成功。
I think those things are always racialized in very particular ways. And so the descriptors of innocence that were so readily attached to Johnny Gosh and Eugene Wade Martin in Iowa and other missing or slain white kids, those descriptors were not applied to the youngsters who were kidnapped and killed in Atlanta. Oftentimes they were described as streetwise, as street hustlers. And so in a way, some of the discourse surrounding their disappearances and deaths serve to legitimate their disappearances and deaths. Many of the children kidnapped in Atlanta were found dead in the weeks and months after they disappeared. But some remained missing. And yet none of them appeared in the National Child Safety Council's Milk Carton campaign. And even for the kids who did end up on milk cartons, the campaign was largely unsuccessful.
在全国儿童安全委员会运动中亮相的 200 个孩子中，只有两个被活着找到了。芭芭拉仍然记得他们接到电话的那天，得知一个名叫小鲍比·史密斯（Bobby Smith Jr.）的男孩被找到了。他们打电话说他被找到了的那天，我们通过对讲机的扬声器让所有人都知道了。那是一种欣喜若狂的感觉，你想让大楼里每一个邮寄过、打包过、发货过的人都知道。你知道，你只是想告诉每一个摸过它的人，这一切都是值得的。你能听到整栋大楼里欢呼雀跃。太好了，我们找到了一个孩子。这真是太棒了，你知道的。但小鲍比·史密斯并不是因为牛奶盒而被找到的。鲍比是巧合被找到的。他绑架者的汽车卷入了一场事故。当警察来寻找车主时，他们找到了鲍比。
Of the 200 kids who were featured in the National Child Safety Council's campaign, only two were ever found alive. Barbara still remembers the day they got the call that a boy named Bobby Smith Jr. was found. The day they called and said that he had been found, we got on the loudspeaker on an intercom and let everyone know. And it was just a sense of elation, and you wanted to let everyone in the building that had mailed it,
但全国运动和较小的本地运动中大多数特色儿童从未被找到。不幸的是，来自牛奶盒的线索并没有揭示约翰尼的下落。那是诺琳·戈什。她的儿子约翰尼永远没有被找到。但她和芭芭拉·哈吉特都坚信这场运动产生了积极的影响。它所做的是提高了人们的意识，让人们开始寻找。他们看到了一个看起来处于痛苦中的孩子。也许你会质疑那是不是亲生父母。
boxed it, shipped it. You know, you just wanted to tell everyone who had touched it that was worthwhile. You could hear the cheer throughout the whole building. Yay, we found a child. It was wonderful, you know. But Bobby Smith wasn't found because of the milk carton. Bobby was found by coincidence. His kidnapper's car had been involved in an accident. And when the police came looking for the owner of the car, they found Bobby.
大多数情况下，牛奶盒只是让人们开始思考绑架问题。我和相当多的成年人交流过，他们还记得他们的妈妈把牛奶盒放在厨房桌子上说：“现在，我们要重新过一遍规则，”他们会以牛奶盒上的男孩为例。然后将那个孩子与他们自己的生活建立联系。换句话说，牛奶盒上的面孔把所有人都吓坏了。
But most of the kids featured in the national campaign and in the smaller, local ones were never found. Unfortunately, the leads from the milk cartons did not reveal where Johnny's location was. That's Noreen Gosh again. Her son, Johnny, was never found. But she and Barbara Huggett are both adamant that the campaign had a positive impact. What it did was promote more awareness so that people were looking. They saw a child that looked like they were in distress. Maybe you questioned whether or not those were the parents.
这最终导致了运动的没落。几乎在牛奶盒运动开始的同时，它们也开始走向尾声。乳业开始从侧面板上撤下失踪儿童的照片。当然，原因之一是行业转向了塑料包装。但乳品厂也开始感到厌烦。
Mostly, the milk cartons just got people thinking about kidnapping. I have talked to quite a number of adults, and they could remember their mom putting the milk carton on the kitchen table and saying, now, we're going to go over the rules again, and they would use the example of the boys on the milk carton. And then make the correlation between that child and their child's life. In other words, the faces on the milk cartons scared the hell out of everyone.
这种压抑的信息。他们把它撤下来，是因为有人抱怨他们认为这可能会在早餐桌上吓到儿童。著名的儿科医生本杰明·斯波克（Benjamin Spock）博士谴责了牛奶盒运动。他说，这是在对人进行心理创伤。
Which ultimately led to the campaign's downfall. Almost as quickly as they began, the milk carton campaigns started to wind down. Darius began to pull the missing kids' pictures from their side panels. One reason, of course, with the cartons is that the industry shifted to plastic. But Darius also started to get tired
孩子们不应该在他们的幸运符麦片上看到这些。他们看到这些失踪的孩子仿佛在盯着他们看。那个牛奶盒几乎迫使他们进行那场对话。如果你看到陌生人或陌生人搭讪该怎么办。那是历史学家保罗·伦弗罗。保罗写了一本关于牛奶盒儿童的书，以及当时席卷社会的巨大恐慌。陌生人危险。保罗研究了当时在新闻、广播和政治家中谈论儿童安全的方式。
of the depressing message. They took it away because there were people that were complaining that they thought it might scare children at the breakfast table. The famous pediatrician, Dr. Benjamin Spock, condemned the milk carton campaign. It was traumatizing, he said.
人们四处散布那些简直是天文数字的数字。人们说美国有 180 万失踪儿童。而“失踪”与“被陌生人绑架”紧密相连。但这根本不是真的。每年大约有 350,000 名儿童被报失踪给当局。大约每天 1,000 人。但联邦调查局（FBI）最近的报告发现，实际被陌生人带走的儿童数量仅占其中的 0.1%。
Kids shouldn't have to face that over their lucky charms. They see these missing kids kind of staring at them. That milk carton almost demands them to have that conversation. What to do if you see a stranger or a stranger accosts you. That's the historian Paul Renfro again. Paul wrote a book about the milk carton kids and the larger panic gripping society at the time. Stranger Danger. Paul studies the way child safety was talked about at this time, in the news, on the radio, by politicians.
引发人们对这类事情产生全国性焦虑的主要案件，通常被假定为陌生人绑架。但绝大多数绑架是由父母或与孩子亲近的人实施的。这反映了一种更大的社会神话，即实施性侵犯的可能性最大的是陌生人不认识受害人的人。这也是一种掩盖或忽视危险真正来源的方式。并不是我们在心中构建的那个潜伏在阴影中的邪恶个体的陌生人。
Folks are kicking around these numbers that are just astronomical. Folks are saying there are 1.8 million missing children in the United States. And missing becomes very closely attached to abducted by strangers. But that just wasn't true. Every year, around 350,000 kids are reported. missing to the authorities. That's around 1,000 every day. But the most recent report from the FBI found that the number of kids who are actually
而是我们熟知其面孔的人。全国儿童安全委员会的运动建立在这个误解之上，他们因只展示被陌生人绑架的孩子而受到批评。但全国各地涌现出规模较小的草根运动，那些没有这些规则的运动。正是其中一个牛奶盒运动最终刊登了一个名叫邦尼·布洛克（Bonnie Bullock）的失踪女孩的面孔。我不是被陌生人绑架的，我是被爱我的人绑架的。
taken by strangers is only 0.1% of that. The major cases that kind of spur national anxiety about this sort of thing are presumed to be stranger kidnappings. But the overwhelming majority of kidnappings are perpetrated by parents or someone close to the child. This mirrors a kind of larger societal myth that those who are more likely to perpetrate sexual assaults are strangers or those who don't know the victim. And that's kind of a way to obscure or overlook the real source of that danger. It's not the stranger that we've constructed in our minds of this kind of evil individual who is lurking in the shadows.
邦尼在牛奶盒上看到了自己的脸后被找到了。1995 年，在牛奶盒运动结束几年后，CBS 播出了全新制作的电视电影《牛奶盒上的面孔》。嘿，伙计们。其中有一个经典场景。过着舒适生活、有着慈爱父母的典型青少年简妮·Johnson（Janie Johnson），有一天在学校的自助餐厅里。太好了，博洛尼亚香肠配腌菜。
but, you know, it's someone whose face we know. The National Child Safety Council's campaign was built on this misconception, and they were criticized for featuring only kids who had been abducted by strangers. But smaller, grassroots campaigns cropped up across the country, ones that didn't have those rules. It was one of these other milk carton campaigns that ended up featuring the face of a missing girl named Bonnie Bullock. I wasn't kidnapped by you. strangers that was kidnapped by people that loved me.
一个朋友把一些牛奶洒在了她的膝盖上。并开始对牛奶盒发表评论。13年前被绑架的3岁小孩，怎么可能有人认得出来？直到这时，简妮才低头看了一眼三岁小女孩的照片。她认出了自己的脸。在我整个童年时期，这部电影一遍又一遍地播放。我想正是这个故事让我知道了牛奶盒儿童，以及你可能被绑架却甚至一无所知的想法。
And Bonnie was found after she saw her own face on the milk carton. In 1995, a few years after the milk carton campaign had ended, CBS aired a brand new made-for-TV movie called The Face on the Milk Carton. Hi, guys. In it, there's a classic scene. Janie Johnson, a typical teenager living a comfortable life with her loving parents, is in the cafeteria one day at school. Great, bologna and relish.
当然这只是虚构，但非常相似的事情已经发生在一个非常真实的名为邦尼·布洛克的女孩身上。我想说我离开的时候，我想我刚过三岁，而我被找到时快七岁了。邦尼不是被陌生人绑架的，而是被她的母亲和继父绑架的。正因为如此，邦尼的爸爸不知道她的故事是否有资格登上牛奶盒。有人把她介绍给这个运动，他说：“嗯，是她妈妈带着她，”你知道的，他们说：“好吧，你知道她在哪里吗？”他说：“不知道。”他们说：“她会回来吗？”
A friend spills some milk on her lap. And starts to comment on the milk carton. How is anyone supposed to recognize a three-year-old kidnapped 13 years ago? Only then does Janie glance down at the picture of the three-year-old girl. And she recognizes her own face. This movie played over and over. again throughout my childhood. And I think it was this story that actually introduced me to the milk carton kids and to the idea that it was possible that you could be kidnapped and not even know it.
你和她谈过吗？有什么消息吗？他说：“没有，我什么都不知道。”他们说：“好吧，那这就被认为是失踪。”一项本地运动决定开始印刷邦尼的照片。与此同时，三岁的邦尼根本不知道自己被绑架了。但她的童年非常奇怪。我不知道我们在哪里开始逃亡。
It was fiction, of course, but something very similar had already happened to a very real little girl named Bonnie Bullock. I want to say I was gone from, I think I was a little after three, and I was found when I was almost seven. Bonnie had been kidnapped, not by a stranger, but by her mother and her stepfather. And because of that, Bonnie's dad didn't know if her story would qualify to get on a milk carton. Someone introduced him to this campaign, and he said, well, it's her mom that has her, you know, and they're like, well, do you know where she is? And he goes, no. And he's like, is she coming back?
我的意思是，我知道我们去过宾夕法尼亚州之类的地方。我们去过圣安东尼奥。我们在一个叫塞班岛的地方待了一段时间。他们在塞班岛待了一年，那是关岛附近的一个小岛。是的，我们住在树林里，就像一个棚子里。接下来是夏威夷，但他们依然非常低调。我们在夏威夷总是待在室内。我记得有一两次在户外。
Have you talked to her? Have anything? He's like, no, I know nothing. And he goes, well, then that's considered missing. A local campaign decided to start printing Bonnie's picture. Meanwhile, three-year-old Bonnie has no idea she's been kidnapped. But her childhood was pretty strange. I don't know where we started on the run.
最后，他们来到了科罗拉多州，她的妈妈和继父开始放松下来。隔壁邻居有很多孩子，邦尼经常去那里玩。我们会玩芭比娃娃，我带了我小小的，你知道的，芭比娃娃箱，我会把它带过去。除了去邻居那里，邦尼几乎不允许离开家。但在一个不寻常的场合，当邦尼七岁时，她的继父带她去了超市。他们需要牛奶。
I mean, I know we went to places like Pennsylvania. We went to San Antonio. We were gone for a while in a place called Saipan. They spend a year in Saipan, this small island near Guam. Yeah, we lived in the woods, like in a shack. Next was Hawaii, but they were still lying pretty low. We stayed inside all the time in Hawaii. I recall maybe one or two times being outside.
我只记得，就像看着并看到有多少盒牛奶。现在的情况是，无论什么品牌都会面向你，而在当时，似乎所有的照片都面向你。他抓起牛奶。他说：“嘿，你知道那是谁吗？嘿，你出名了，你知道吗？”他就像：“看，看，你在这里。”我说：“哦。”
Finally, they end up in Colorado, and her mom and stepdad start to relax a bit. The next door neighbors had a bunch of kids, and Bonnie would play over there all the time. We would play Barbies, and I had my little, you know, Barbie case, and I would bring that over. Aside from going to her neighbors, Bonnie was. hardly ever allowed to leave the house. But on an unusual occasion, when Bonnie was seven years old, her stepdad took her to the supermarket. They needed milk.
我看到了自己。我说：“哦，那是真的我吗？”他像：“嘘，嘘。”邦尼的继父买下了印有她脸的牛奶盒。当他们喝完后，他问了她一个问题。“你想要吗？你想留着吗？”所以，我记得把它剪下来，心里想：“哇，”并盯着照片。
I just remember, like, looking and seeing how many cartons of milk there were. Nowadays, it's like whatever brand it is would be facing you, whereas at that time, it seemed like all the pictures were facing you. He grabbed the milk. He's like, hey, do you know who that is? Hey, you're famous, you know? he's like, look, look, you're here. And I was like, oh.
我想我的头发梳成侧边的小马尾辫。我穿着这条小裙子。他说：“现在你得把它保存在一个安全的地方。”我一定把它扔进了我的芭比娃娃箱里。此时，邦尼还不知道有什么不对劲。我知道当时我不会阅读，因为如果我会的话，我会意识到我失踪了，因为照片上实际上写着失踪儿童然后是我的名字和日期。七岁的时候，她还不会认字。
And I saw myself. And I was like, ooh, is that me? And he's like, hush, shh. Bonnie's stepdad bought the milk carton with her face on it. And when they finished it, he asked her a question. Do you want it? You want to keep it? And so I remember cutting it out and being like, whoa, and staring at the picture.
邦尼不记得自己去过真正的学校。他对自己的自信如此之高，以至于他可以向我展示那个，因为不会发生任何事情。但下一次邦尼在邻居家时，她把带有从牛奶盒上剪下来的自己脸的照片的芭比娃娃箱留在了那里。我记得几天后我又去那里，我说：“哦，我把我的芭比娃娃落下了，我能拿回我的芭比娃娃吗？”妈妈在那儿。我记得她说：“哦，邦尼，我们找到了这张你的漂亮照片。”她说：“这是你吗？”我说：“对，对，是我。我很有名。”她说：“哦，你叫邦尼·布洛克吗？”我说：“不，不，不，我叫邦尼·史密斯。”她说：“哦，”她说：
And I think my hair was like in a little ponytail on the side. And I was wearing this little dress. He's like, now you got to keep it in, you know, a safe. place and I must have tossed it in my Barbie case. At this moment, Bonnie didn't know that anything was wrong. I know I didn't read then because I would have realized that I was missing because on the picture it actually said missing child and then my name and the date. At seven years old, she couldn't read.
“我没有你的照片。”她说：“你介意我留着它吗？”我说：“哦，我不知道你是否被允许留着它。”她说：“哦，我会马上还给你的。我能把它贴在冰箱上留一小会儿吗？”我说：“好吧，”我说：“好吧。”不久之后，一切都变了。我记得有很多警察出现，很多警察出现。警察包围了邦尼的家。她被带走并回到了父亲身边，但起初重聚并不容易。
Bonnie doesn't remember ever going to a real school. He was so confident in himself that he could show me that because nothing's going to happen with it. But one of the next times Bonnie was at the neighbor's house, she left her Barbie case there with the picture she cut out of her own face on the milk carton. And I remember going back over there a couple days later and I was like, oh, I left my Barbies, can I get my Barbies? And the mom was there. And I remember her being like, oh, Bonnie, we found this beautiful picture of you. And she was like, is this you? And I was like, yeah, yeah, it's me. I'm famous. And she was like, oh, is your name Bonnie Bullock and I go, no, no, no, my name's Bonnie Smith. And she's like, oh, she's like,
我记得我很害怕，因为我不认识我爸爸，我只想和她在一起。这有点糟糕，你知道的。回到父亲身边后，邦尼过上了相当正常的生活。她开始上学，上了大学，最终成为了一名护士。她是牛奶盒运动中少数几个成功的故事之一。
I don't have any pictures of you. She goes, do you care if I keep it? And I was like, oh, I don't know if you're, you're allowed to keep it. And she goes, oh, I'll give it right back. Can I just keep it for a little bit on the refrigerator? And I was like, yeah, I was like, okay. Not long after, everything changed. I remember there are a lot of police showing up, a lot a police showing up. Police swarmed Bonnie's home. She was whisked away and returned to her father, but the reunion wasn't easy at first.
我相信我是现在的我，是因为我在牛奶盒上被找到了，你知道的，我在和爸爸一起长大的过程中拥有了和我妈妈在一起可能不会有的机会。我能够过上美好的生活，对此我很感激。她的故事虽然是一部标准的电视电影的题材，但实际上比许多登上头条的失踪儿童案件更具代表性。它只是强调了绑架问题的现实，对吧？这是历史学家保罗·伦弗罗。
I remember being scared because I didn't know my dad, and all I wanted to do was be with her. It kind of sucked, you know. After returning to her dad, Bonnie had a pretty normal life. She started school, went on to college, and eventually became a nurse. She's one of the Mill Carton Campaign's,
这是一个主要属于家庭和熟人的问题。它真的不是一个专注于陌生人的问题，尽管那是 80 年代和 90 年代最令人恐惧并推动这种恐慌的现象。不幸的是，陌生人危险并没有停止在 80 年代和 90 年代推动恐慌，尽管恐惧本身已经发生了一些变异。今晚最新消息，华盛顿特区一家受欢迎的比萨店成为社交媒体风暴的中心，被指控为贩运儿童进行邪教仪式及更糟糕事情的人口贩卖温室。其实一切始于推特。就在 2016 年大选前几周，一个理论开始席卷推特和红迪网（Reddit）。
few success stories. I believe that I am who I am because I was on a milk carton and I was found and, you know, I had opportunities with my dad growing up that I might not have had with my mom. I was able to live a great life and I'm grateful for it. Her story, while the stuff of a literal made-for-TV movie, is actually much more representative than a lot of the missing child cases that made headlines. It just underscores the reality of the problem of kidnapping, right? This is historian Paul Renfro again.
标签“披萨门”（Pizza Gate），暴徒们正在传播一个虚构的故事，即华盛顿特区西北部一家受欢迎的比萨店是儿童性奴隶团伙的中心。这种观点认为，民主党，特别是希拉里·克林顿周围的人，正在绑架和虐待儿童，他们这一切都在一家比萨店里完成。现在不仅是陌生人在带走你的孩子，而是政治精英。红迪网的侦探们认为克林顿和她的竞选经理约翰·波德斯塔（John Podesta）正在利用地下隧道进入一家名为“彗星乒乓”（Comet Pingpong）的比萨店的地下室。这个阴谋论听起来可能很荒谬，但它赢得了许多信徒的支持，他们不断出现在这家餐厅。这个故事被亚历克斯·琼斯（Alex Jones）在 Info Wars 和大纪元时报（The Epoch Times）上报道。
It is a problem that is primarily one of the family and of acquaintances. It really is not one that's focused on strangers, even though that is the phenomenon that is most feared and the one that drove this panic in the 80s and 90s, Unfortunately, stranger danger didn't stop driving panic in the 80s and 90s, though the fear itself has kind of mutated. New tonight, a popular DC pizza joint is at the center of a social media firestorm accused of being a human trafficking hotspot using children for satanic rituals and worse. It begins on Twitter, actually. Just weeks before the 2016 election, a theory starts to take Twitter and read it by storm.
抗议者出现在比萨店外。死亡威胁接踵而至。彗星乒乓的员工一直收到很多这样的威胁。现在它正在蔓延到附近的其他企业。几周后，事态真正升级了。它促使一个人从北卡罗来纳州开车来到彗星乒乓比萨店，试图解放那些表面上被奴役并作为人质关在彗星乒乓地下室的儿童。当然，他带了武器到达。
the hashtag Pizza Gate, the vandals are spreading an imaginary story that the popular Northwest D.C. Pizza shop is the center of a child sex slave ring. This notion that the Democratic Party and specifically folks in the orbit of Hillary Clinton were abducting and abusing children and they were doing all of this in a pizza parlor. Now it's not just strangers taking your kids, it's political elites. Reddit sleuths believed that Clinton and her campaign manager, John Podesta, were using underground tunnels to access the basement of a pizza place called Comet Pingpong. The conspiracy theory may sound absurd, but it has won over lots of believers who keep turning up at the restaurant. The story gets picked up by Alex Jones at Info Wars and the epoch times.
他准备为这个事业牺牲。他开了几枪，谢天谢地没有击中任何人，但很快得知彗星乒乓根本没有地下室。当然，那个不存在的地下室里也没有孩子。我认为“披萨门”和枪击事件确实概括了许多导致牛奶盒运动发展的恐惧和焦虑。围绕它的儿童安全运动，从这场运动中滋生的许多立法，以及关于人口贩卖和性贩卖的广泛恐惧，还有美国某些政治精英据称放荡的行为。
Protesters show up outside the pizza place. Death threats start pouring in. and staff at Comet Pingpong have been getting plenty of those threats. And now it is spreading to other nearby businesses. And it really escalated a few weeks later. It spurred an individual to drive up from North Carolina to the Comet Pingpong parlor and try to liberate the children who were ostensibly being enslaved and held hostage in the basement of the Comet Pingpong. And of course, he arrived armed.
但不幸的是，众所周知，政治精英确实一直在做出放荡的行为。我的意思是，随着我们开始更多地了解杰弗里·爱泼斯坦（Jeffrey Epstein）丑闻，这一切变得复杂起来，它在某种程度上证实了这些精英集团、儿童性虐待团伙的说法。对的。我认为，在许多方面，是的，它确实证实了一个致力于虐待年轻人的集团的存在。
He was ready to die for this cause. He fired several rounds and thankfully didn't strike anybody, but soon learned that there is no basement to the comet ping pong. And of course, there were no kids in the non-existent basement. I think Pizza Gate and the shooting incident really encapsulates, I think, a lot of the fears and anxieties that led to the development of the milk carton campaign. the child safety campaign around it, a lot of the legislation that grew out of that movement, and these broader fears of human trafficking and sex trafficking, and the supposedly debauchous acts of certain political elites in the United States.
但围绕爱泼斯坦档案的大多数言论都试图将这些档案武器化，为政治项目特别是党派项目服务。我认为政治光谱的任何一边都是如此。因此，它没有关注受害者或关注根除虐待和剥削，而是被用来捞取微不足道的党派政治资本。事情是这样的。爱泼斯坦档案记录了值得认真对待的真实虐待行为。肇事者应该被追究责任。但这并不是这个故事以这种方式占据美国人想象力的唯一原因。这也是因为这些档案似乎证实了我们最根深蒂固的阴谋论和我们最糟糕的恐惧。但它们描绘了一幅与实际威胁绝大多数美国儿童的现实大相径庭的画面，那是一种更加世俗的东西。
But unfortunately, as we all know, political elites have indeed been committing debauchous acts. I mean, this all gets complicated by the fact that as we start learning more about Jeffrey Epstein scandal, it kind of confirms this sense of a cabal of these elites of a child sex abuse ring. Right. I think, so in many ways, yes, it does confirm the existence of a cabal that is invested in in abusing young people.
爱泼斯坦档案与它们似乎证实的一切之间，显然存在着一种张力，而现实是儿童更有可能被他们认识的人、家庭成员剥削。我认为，爱泼斯坦档案及其周围的言论只会加剧对这类事情的误解和混乱。并且无助于或阻碍对儿童性虐待的实际定性以及对儿童性虐待的更深理解。议长先生，国内儿童贩卖是一个严重的问题，可悲的是在美国。
But a lot of the discourse surrounding the Epstein files seeks to weaponize those files in the service of a political project and specifically a partisan project. And I think this is true on either side of the political aisle. So instead of focusing on victims or focusing on the eradication of abuse and exploitation, it's being used to score petty partisan points. Here's the thing. The Epstein files document real abuse that deserves to be taken seriously. The perpetrators should be held accountable. But that's not the only reason the story has consumed the American imagination in the way that it has. It's also that the files seem to confirm our stickiest conspiracy theories and our worst fears. But they paint a picture that is very different than what actually
在过去的几十年里，关于儿童性贩卖的一个统计数据占据了主导地位。每年大约有 30 万美国青年面临遭受性商业剥削和贩卖的风险。国内每天有大约 30 万儿童被贩运。有 30 万美国儿童面临被贩运进行性交易的风险。研究表明，超过 29 万名青年。将近 30 万美国儿童面临风险。估计有 10万到 30万名女孩。
threatens most American children, which is something much more mundane. There's a tension clearly between the Epstein files and everything they seem to verify and the reality that children are far more likely to be exploited by people they know, by family members. The Epstein files and the discourse surrounding them, I think, will only sort of exacerbate the misunderstanding and exacerbate the confusion around these sorts of matters. and they will not contribute or will deter from the actual sort of naming of child sexual abuse and a deeper understanding of child sexual abuse. Mr. Speaker, domestic child trafficking is a serious problem, sadly in the United States.
这一统计数据被立法者引用。超过 30 万。被名人、非营利组织引用。此外，联邦调查局估计，每年有超过 30 万名女孩。美国儿童面临性剥削和贩卖的风险。这已经深入人心。迈阿密大学一位政治科学家进行的调查发现，全国有一半以上的人认为每年被贩运的孩子数量在 30 万或以上。
In the last few decades, one statistic about child sex trafficking has taken hold. Around 300,000 American youth are at risk of sexual commercial exploitation. and trafficking each year. It's in the neighborhood of 300,000 children domestically that are being trafficked every day. That 300,000 American children are at risk of being trafficked for sex. Studies suggest that over 290,000 youth. Almost 300,000 American children are at risk. There are estimates between 100,000 to 300,000 girls.
我们谈论得越多，我们就越能改变它并阻止它。非常感谢您提供的信息，也感谢您在这方面对我进行教育。我很感激。但这个数字错得离谱。它来自 2001 年的一项研究，该研究计算的不是儿童性贩卖受害者的数量，而是有多少孩子可能处于危险之中。这意味着寄宿家庭或公共住房中的儿童，住在边境附近或有机会接触汽车的儿童。儿童性贩卖是一个真实的问题，只是没有达到这个规模。这些犯罪的性质是它们被低估了，但我们拥有的统计数据讲述了一个截然不同的故事。
The statistic is cited by lawmakers. More than 300,000. By celebrities, by nonprofits. Furthermore, the FBI has estimated that over 300,000 girls. American children are at risk of sexual exploitation and trafficking annually. And it's stuck with the public. A survey done by the University of Miami political scientist found that over half of the country believes that the number of kids who are trafficked each year is 300,000 or more.
2021 年，从事儿童性贩卖案件的联邦调查局特工确认的未成年受害者略多于 500 名。不是 30 万，而是 500。一些数据表明，在近一半的案件中，贩卖儿童的不是陌生人，而是与他们亲近的人。在美国，这显然是一个严重的问题，但我们宁愿通过这些更大、更虚幻的叙事来扭曲它。我认为，说这是邪恶的陌生人，而不是更大的结构性问题，要舒服得多。
The more we talk about it, the more we can change it and stop it. Thank you so much for your information and for educating me about this too. I appreciate it. But this number is incredibly wrong. It comes from a study back in 2001, a study that wasn't calculating the number of victims of child sex trafficking, but how many kids might be at risk. And that meant kids in foster homes or public housing, kids who lived near borders or had access to a car. Child sex trafficking is a real problem, just not at this scale. The nature of these crimes is that they're underreported, but the statistics we do have tell a very different story.
我想我的问题是，为什么你认为我们会被这些对儿童真正危险的虚幻叙事所吸引？什么让人感觉良好？对的。拒绝审视真正滋生这种虐待的实际关系是舒服的，把这种威胁局部化在我们已经觉得危险或已经觉得可疑的力量中会更容易。是的，奇怪的是，说实际上是个人把儿童作为人质关在比萨店里让人感觉很舒服。
In 2021, FBI agents working on child sex trafficking cases identified just over 500 victims who are underage. Not 300,000, but 500. And some data suggests that for nearly half of all cases, the child is trafficked not by a child. stranger, but by someone close to them. In the United States, it most clearly is a serious, a grave problem, but it's one that we would rather distort through these larger, more fantastical narratives. I think it's far more comforting to say it's nefarious strangers rather than a larger kind of structural problem.
或者是那些在世界各地飞来飞去、抢走儿童并将他们带到岛上的人，而不是真正去质疑自己以及他们对家庭、对他们珍视的这些宗教机构或政治和社会机构的承诺。没有任何事物能比牛奶盒以更持久的方式带来这种奇怪的安慰。在短短几年时间里，五亿个牛奶盒出现在美国每一个厨房里，讲述着同一个故事：威胁就在外面。在牛奶盒运动结束后，失踪儿童的照片开始出现在各种其他事物上。披萨盒、塑料杂货袋、水电费账单。事实上，水电费账单运动比牛奶盒持续的时间要长得多，
I guess my question is, like, why do you think that we gravitate towards these fantastical narratives of what is actually dangerous for children? Like, what feels good about that? Right. It's comforting to refuse to interrogate the actual relationships that do spawn this sort of abuse, and it's easier to localize that threat within forces that we already find dangerous or we already find suspicious. Yes, it is strangely comforting to say it's actually individuals who are holding children hostage in a pizza parlor
但我们大多数人甚至都没听说过。它就是没有流行起来。在牛奶盒侧面看到一张脸，有一种不同的东西。我认为牛奶有助于构建一种家庭团结感，一种母性滋养感，同时也是人们在早餐桌旁聚集的周围物品。因此，将失踪孩子的面孔放在该物品上是相当深思熟虑的，也许这就是为什么
or individuals who were flying all over the world, snatching children and taking them to an island, then to really kind of question oneself and the sorts of commitments they have to the family, to these religious institutions or political and social institutions that they hold dear. Nothing delivered this strange comfort in a more lasting way than the milk carton. For a few short years, five billion milk cartons sat in every kitchen in America, telling the same story, that the threat is out there. After the milk carton campaign ended, pictures of missing children started showing up on all kinds of other things. pizza boxes, plastic grocery bags, utility bills. Actually, the utility bill campaign went on for much longer than the milk cartons,
这能一直延续下去的原因。《美国简史与 100 件物品》是 99% Invisible 和 BBC Studios 联合制作的节目。由我罗曼·马尔斯主持和策划。我们的系列制作人是普里西拉·阿拉·B、布伦纳·达尔多夫和埃莉·莱特福特。我们的副制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔编辑，查理·布兰登·金混音。艾米·布拉克肯进行事实核查。我们的主题曲由斯旺·里尔创作。
but most of us haven't even heard of it. It just didn't stick. There was something different about seeing a face on the side of a milk carton. There is a sense of familial unity that I think milk helps to author, the sense of maternal nurturance, and also being this kind of item around which people, gather around the breakfast table. So putting missing kids' faces on that item was quite deliberate and perhaps the reason why
来自 99% Invisible，我们的执行制作人是凯蒂·图。来自 BBC Studios，我们的执行制作人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是香·帕莱，制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特。插图由斯特凡·劳伦斯绘制。99% Invisible 是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。BBC Studios 总部位于伦敦西部美丽的白城。如果您想取得联系或有物品让我们考虑，请发送电子邮件至 100objects@99pi.org。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
that lives on. A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. Our series producers are Priscilla Alaw B, Brenna Dahldorf, and Ellie Lightfoot. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real.
这个传奇将继续延续下去。《美国简史与100件物品》是 99% Invisible 和 BBC Studios 联合制作的节目。由我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）主持并策划。我们的系列制作人是普里西拉·阿拉·B（Priscilla Alaw B）、布伦娜·达尔多夫（Brenna Dahldorf）和埃莉·莱特富特（Ellie Lightfoot）。我们的助理制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔（Isaac Fisher）。本系列由安妮·布朗（Annie Brown）和考特尼·哈雷尔（Courtney Harrell）剪辑，查理·布兰登·王（Charlie Brandon King）混音。事实核查由艾米·布雷肯（Amy Bracken）负责。我们的主题曲由 Swan Real 创作。
From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright. Artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM podcast, family headquartered in Beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful, White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 objects at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 99% Invisible 的执行制作人是凯西·2（Kathy 2）。来自 BBC Studios 的执行制作人是安妮·布朗（Annie Brown）和考特尼·哈雷尔（Courtney Harrell）。我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱斯（Shan Palais），制作经理是马贝尔·芬尼根·赖特（Mabel Finnegan Wright）。插图由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。99% Invisible 是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。BBC Studios 总部位于美丽的伦敦西部白城。如果您想与我们取得联系或有物品让我们考虑，请发送电子邮件至 100 objects at 99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。